i just found this all the time
we were talking during the break about
that old western town you know that
they're making the real estate uh
fantasy that's like inspired by
yellowstone i really want to move in i
could open a little bonnet shop and a
little singles bar called can you
imagine a singles bar called the hoe
down just come on now
right
on top i love it all right all right you
got right
we do have a new design trend you know i
just got a new house drew's going to
help me because i like every wall is
white i'm so scared of anything and i'm
not alone but there are a lot of people
using colors and apartment therapy
reports wallpaper is flying off the
shelf specifically floured wallpaper
people yeah they're putting the pedal to
the metal
and we're talking in the first half of
january alone sales of wallpaper went up
wow
412 percent you guys
so what is behind this drew i've always
been scared to do it because i think i'm
going to mess it up i wouldn't even know
who to call to put wallpaper up but
people are figuring it out well you're
calling the right person every wallpaper
you just saw uh we made and designed
with flower homes that's all yours
we're ours um would you ever do a floral
wallpaper 100 like i love the idea of a
powder room with a bold wallpaper right
when you walk into a small bathroom it's
like a lot i always go oh like that
makes me so happy can i do a design by
drew in your new house a powder room
edition any room you want done
done
done done
[Applause]
done i'm so excited oh project
for rothie next up a brief woman named
milay nah went viral on tick tock and
asked what's your crappiest dating story
it was mine took place last summer
i talked about it a million times it's
true it was the worst in the first 10
minutes i was like get me out of here
really tell me why again which one was
this he told me he had the affair that
blew up his marriage and his daughter
found out and i'm just like oh wow
what's wrong with you you are messy
messy
messy do you remember my worst day ever
i was on a date with a guy it was going
well we had fun and then his boyfriend
showed up because
because it apparently it wasn't a date
it was just
hanging with a friend how do you think
you misunderstood the situation or did
he mislead you i just assumed it was my
fault somewhere along the way i just
assumed yeah i mean i guess i should
have been clear it's like when you asked
me to dinner and drinks alone i should
have asked if it was a date
yeah
we have pretty bad stories drew but when
i read this story i think this woman
might have topped us oh this one is
gnarly get ready for this
the sun report she wasn't quite ready
for the answer of like what is your
worst dating story because a woman
walked into her date's house to find at
his bedside that he was building a tower
out of every piece of chewing gum he'd
ever
is that a picture of it wait is that a
picture of it yeah i know and i can't
even look at it oh my god i can't even
look at it making one of you oh my god
you know what that pile needs is a
bucket right next to it so i can just
every time i look at the pile now ross
is this a story you can chew on or what
i try
um sammy told us the story that i i
don't think i can even share it it's so
foul sammy our producer i thought she
said she knew someone who collected
booker
[Applause]
she didn't she knew someone who knew
someone
i'm just saying
maybe maybe our lives aren't so bad
rossi
maybe we're getting out pretty clean
things are looking up
[Music]
you